today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
today's guest is a unique man he's had a
he's had a lifestyle an experience that
not many get to have he's led a uh
he's led a rare path
um
he is
he is celebrated and discussed
ad nauseam
you might say i think that means getting
sick i don't know what that means
exactly but
uh we're happy to have him here today
he's um
retired nfl quarterback and the host of
uncut with jay cutler it is
the man himself mr jay cutlers
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my stories
me
[Applause]
we're grateful you're coming in i know
you got a podcast starting up we have a
lot of podcast listeners over the years
with this podcast on a different podcast
so um
i know you went on nate the other day
it's pretty cool yeah uh
cause nate's a big um
nate's a big fan he's a big vanderbilt
fan huge fandy fan yeah from here grew
up here
um
and he's in there he's funny as hell too
he means it oh yeah
yeah nate bargatsi he's really that um
[Music]
he's a real more of a scientist of like
humor i feel like he's like yeah
like it's calculated almost like he he
sets it up like he's he's got his whole
thing and whenever whenever he walked in
you don't really know like i just
started doing this podcast stuff so you
don't really know how it's going to go
with somebody you don't know like doing
something with somebody you know you're
like all right i've got this down i got
this figured out
but when he walked in i was like [ __ ] i
don't this might not go well yeah yeah
yeah yeah because he's you know he was
you know not a lot of emotion just kind
of just sat down and he's like
i was like oh boy he's real passive yeah
he's a calm guy i'm trying to feel it it
almost sometimes feels with nate like
i'm getting in trouble for something
yeah in the beginning but then once you
kind of get to know that he's just um
it's just kind of some of his demeanor
exactly he's real smart
he's a real smart guy man
um
yeah what else going on not much i had a
freaking bad dream last night do you
ever have those dreams like i just get
shocked sometimes like even as an adult
that i'll have these dreams where i'll
like wake up and i'm like what's up
you know i'll be like drooling i was
like what up
there you know what i'm talking about at
all i know you're talking about it i
don't feel like i dream that much
anymore i don't know what that says
about me it might not might not be a
good thing
yeah or it might be a good thing
you might have to get your chakras
worked on or something man i have a
couple indian buddies and they're always
like dude your chakras are bad and i'm
like how do you fix that that's what
i'll you know i try to get into it with
them and it's like i would love to get
my chakras fixed yeah
oh dude that would be a good show of
something uh jay cutler gets his chakras
fixed that's a good choice that's a
great idea yeah i gotta i need to write
this down i need to look into this it
may you may need a construction worker
though
i might need like five of these guys in
here
one guy's not gonna fix me yeah you may
need a little bit of work man um
yeah i'm trying to think so you got the
new podcast when i was this this is
called liquid death that's a water
company
from the
austrian alps
yeah it almost sounds a little i don't
want to say nazi water but it's good
definitely it sounds like on the can i
don't know who's stone cold mountain
water
came straight from the alps to murder
your thirst
you've got like cool sponsors it's this
stuff's good man they've been good uh
it's pretty good you know they mail us a
lot of water man that's nice i'll send
you a couple cases on my name you don't
need it i know you're doing well yeah
but i'll put up we'll throw a couple
cases yeah maybe i'll just put it on my
podcast and just be like hey i'm just
doing this oh what they did i bet they'd
probably get on board yeah you know
i mean the amount of like weird ad
sponsor requests
is is mind-boggling to me what did you
have to read i didn't see your ads yet
on your first set on youtube we did a uh
i should know this
i really should it's okay if you don't
yeah i did a
like a
helicopter
basically a helicopter ambulance
oh really so if you're hurt somewhere
and you can't get a hot get to a
hospital this you pay a 149 a year no
way and this helicopter will come and
get you and take you to a hospital
dude that's saying i didn't even know it
was a thing it sounds like it sounds
very something that would happen to like
somebody in mexico i feel like it sounds
like a kidnapping or more like a
colombian type of thing
i mean i kind of i mean i kind of want
to do it just like call them up and see
what happens
hey guys yeah i'm having a tough time
spreading my ankle i need i need a lift
i'm out at lake radnor
i got bit by a duck i need to go home
yeah
um i was pretty shocked a few years ago
when uber like
there was something was going on in the
world when pete like um
was it the olympics i don't remember
what it was but when uber started having
play airplanes on their thing do you
yeah i do remember that they stay and
they started doing um airplanes
helicopters and i think they were trying
to get in like the freight business
people were getting rich that's when i
realized holy [ __ ] man people are rich
dude
yeah if you can just dial up a plane on
uber yeah 10 grand
yeah no big deal charge it it starts
feeling to me recently i felt like
during the pandemic that there's so many
more rich people or that money doesn't
mean anything i have these weird
thoughts yeah i think now i don't
understand how people like are
functioning like i don't feel like
anybody works yeah but everyone's just
spending money
i don't know if people are in debt and
they just don't care or what's happening
and everyone's just driving around yeah
doesn't it feel fictional yeah it's like
everyone's just cruising around people
are out having a great time like what
yeah they're buying champagne people are
buying nice hats people buying jewelry i
mean there's like 200 people a day that
moved to this town yeah people just
buying houses left and right
and houses are getting expensive man
even
like even a great like you'll see a
groundhog and even he looks like he's
got some money you know what i'm saying
like the land here is getting a little
bit oh it's absurd it's absolutely i
mean i i
i mean i hope people are doing well yeah
yeah i do
i hope that like
in a couple years like we just
we just fall off the cliff
and it's like well i saw this one coming
guys that's what it i feel like i see it
coming but nothing else it's not kind of
making sense maybe to other people like
i don't know what it is but yeah i'm
just shocked like i have some friends
that are pretty rich sometimes and they
um they say that they'll be like on
runways and stuff or like where
everybody's everybody has private jets
and stuff and they said there's like so
many more private jets now they're
everywhere
but it's also there's also like
everyone's doing a podcast everyone's
doing social media yeah but i mean
people have to be buying people have to
be buying liquid death yeah
people have to be buying what people are
selling on instagram
i don't know i'm confused by the world
at this point in my life i think yeah i
feel like it gets a little tricky um
because you really jay cutler i mean you
really you're jay cutler man and you
really had a big i mean you've had such
a neat experience dude i always wanted
to be like because you always seem like
the tall kind of like you know like
you know what i'm saying bro i prefer
women but you seem like a tall decent
looking man i'll be on you know what i'm
saying i'll give you at least eight and
a half dude
my kids gave me a uh
a seven last night
i don't even know how this conversation
happened but they gave me a seven
and i was like are you guys serious i'm
a seven and they're like keep it up
we'll get we'll make you a six yeah
kids are dicey bro
they also tell the truth so i mean maybe
they're right it is a six maybe six and
a half
i mean i think in this town there's i
feel like there's a there's almost more
competition i feel like in some ways in
a city like nashville because there's
i feel like here there's a lot more like
kind of manly dudes sometimes
well i've been living in l.a and there
it's a lot more oh you crush l.a i'm
sure like you're a dude out there yeah
out there chicks yeah yeah what's going
on you know tell me about the squirrels
real low-key [ __ ] yeah like what can i
eat if i'm lost in the woods you know
and i'm like i'd have a neutral grain
bar but you know what i'm saying my
backpack yeah yeah
nationals change like you're used to i
mean
you know early 2000 i've been here since
2000 for the most part so like it's
complete the whole demographic has
completely changed there was no one here
really it was like a small
click of people you knew everybody
yeah you go downtown now it's like you
don't know anybody
at all yeah yeah it's really intense
down there too um that's too much but is
it interesting like so you got so yeah i
always like man i always wish i could
have been like the taller guy you know
you're pretty tall how tall are you i'm
six foot i'm regular height i think i
think 510 is regular is it what's the
average height of humans it's got to be
it's north american humans too please
sean male
yeah
yeah yeah but it nailed it
five nine i mean you're crushing it yeah
you're right actually dang i didn't know
that five nine
that's almost
rising
cdc everything they say is 100 who knows
yeah so this could be
i mean somebody could have just uploaded
this an hour ago
that's the crazy thing about the
internet and the world right now it's
like
no information
it's like everybody believes so much
information but none of uh it's like i
believe less and less because i put out
information and people will tell me like
oh man that's real and i'm like i don't
know no idea yeah
and everyone's got an agenda like it
depends like who you got it from like
there's everyone's spinning something
it's just
it's just hard to trust anything yeah
that's the thing i think so then i go
back to my instincts and sometimes my
instincts i feel like
usually have served me pretty good but
it's sometimes it's hard to know yeah um
when you look it back at like so now
you're not a quarterback now yeah you'll
always be a quarterback but you're not
doing it no like on a day-to-day basis i
don't get paid anymore right you're not
getting paid yeah i guess maybe that
defines it
do you look at and see like man what a
position i was in like is it different
to look
like sometimes i'll look at things in my
life and be like man i didn't kind of
not realize the position i was in but
you know like to to a regular man
looking at a quarterback you're like
dang that's the guy you know that's
odysseus or whatever yeah i mean
that's a great point like looking back
on it now like you get tunnel vision and
like you don't you don't maybe enjoy it
or have as much fun or take advantage of
it as much as
you would would now looking back on it i
mean you're just locked in and you're
just doing your job and you know it
turns sometimes it's a grind sometimes
it's fun
sometimes it's really hard um but
looking back on it now um you know it
i don't say i don't want to say that i
wish i would have done things
differently but it it it wasn't it was
an awesome awesome experience
it was an awesome experience it was an
awesome experience yeah yeah
it's probably and it shapes a lot of
like who i am and you know the people i
associate with and and how i respond to
things and
so i mean it's it's a
you know from the time i was fourth
grade till you know 35 it kind of shaped
me
yeah this can't i was trying to think
about something in my life that had been
that much of like a [ __ ] like a thing
that i
was like a vehicle in my life
and i don't know if
i've had that so it just must seem a lot
that you know you're in like a new
career it's like you're trying to find
are you do you want to find a new career
do you feel like you need to or are you
just
kind of like um
i don't know like what do you think like
do you feel like a pressure to or do you
just yeah i mean
because i mean like not many people when
they're 35 or whatever age people are
playing football like
have to go out there and in the real
world and like figure out figure out the
rest of your life right
so
a career career i don't know if that's
the right word i think like for me it's
more like purpose like what what is
going to drive me what gives me purpose
in my life going forward um and there
was pressure when i when i got out to
like to figure that out
and i was never one of those guys that
had other businesses or stuff going on
when i played it was literally i just i
played football like i had plan a and
there was no backup
and so now when i got out it was just
like all right i'm
i'm clueless what i'm gonna do i have no
idea
i know the football's over
i knew i didn't want to coach i knew i
wanted to kind of get out of that world
so it was really just trying to figure
out all right what the hell am i going
to wake up and be happy doing gives me a
sense of purpose
i like it i like the people i'm working
with
and that took time you know and i'm
probably still kind of figuring that one
out
so when you start because i was yeah i
was watching your first episode um and
it's called uh uncut with jake uncut
with jay cutler or something like that
yeah and you're jay cutler dude and
yeah yeah yeah
they'll figure it out google um
yeah i was like because it's because
it's injury because you're definitely
kind of like this you kind of remind me
of a cross between like christian later
and like sasquatch a little like you're
kind of like this
yeah and it's i don't mean it in a
negative way i love that okay cool
yeah it's like a um
yeah you're kind of like this
interesting figure that the media gave a
lot of attention to like weird attention
kind of and [ __ ]
but that's kind of the best you know in
a way nowadays that's almost like the
best kind of attention you can get out
there in a weird way it's like
it's not super real nobody really knows
what's going on yeah there's a vagueness
there to it and
you know it wasn't intentional um you
know i think there's just certain
aspects of my life that i like keep in
private
that you know i don't really talk about
um
and i'm probably gonna try to keep it
that way yeah uh
and i i i think that you know i did a
reality show for a little bit after i
was done and
you know i think as soon as you start
like pulling back and like kind of
shielding yourself some like people
really want to get into that and figure
that out and know more um so i think
that kind of played into it but you know
the podcast i don't know where that's
going to go yeah but it's kind of cool
that's what i noticed in your opening it
was like kind of like
you weren't trying to be too much i
didn't feel like or trying to be a
certain thing you're kind of like i
don't know where this is going to go no
idea you know
um and and that was the hard part about
doing it um
of of doing the opening like the
interviews and stuff is that's easy like
but like for me i was like i don't i
don't know what to say in this opening
thing
and
i don't really want to say too much
about me i really don't want to
divulge like a lot going forward right
now so like this
i'm gonna tell him you know i don't know
what the hell i'm doing yeah we're gonna
have some fun maybe it works maybe it
doesn't work but let's just do this and
go
it's funny man because it kind of
reminded me too when i started
podcasting i just started in my kitchen
i didn't really know when did you start
i started maybe about five years ago
maybe or four years ago i'd gone on joe
rogan's podcast a couple of times maybe
that's a marathon that's not a podcast
oh dude it was so hard what are you guys
how does he have like does he have like
a like a notebook of stuff oh he just he
just goes he's a notebook man yeah he is
a notebook he's incredible oh dude he's
like a swiss army notebook yeah he um
but i mean is there an option like to be
like after like an hour of like tapping
out or like you're just stuck i think
you want to but i think part of the
mystique about joe rogans is that you go
in there and you're like
you know i want to be able to go toe to
toe you know what i'm saying he's kind
of like this um this symbol of of not
necessarily just machismo but somewhat
of machismo for sure yeah so you want to
be able to be like okay i can do my time
you know it's like i hung in there with
him yes yeah and it's you're just like
dude and you hit about two hours and you
have a cramp that you're trying to deny
and you're still trying to like get your
bathroom yeah totally he'll do a
bathroom break sometimes
um
i remember at one point i remember
saying hey man this is the longest
conversation i've ever been in my entire
life for sure
and it was and it was like almost scary
to think that yeah that i'm talking to a
man that that uh
that i've gotten to know better but i
didn't know super great at the time sure
that was scary man i feel like it's a
it's going in there it's kind of scary
because then they close the door and the
sound kind of gets whoo
it's just you guys
and you almost think he can hear like
you like the internet's in your head
yeah he's just like peering through your
brain like he's got that third ear yeah
bro some people got that third eye
sometimes i feel like joe has that third
here man um
but but that really helped like kind of
get get it going i think
doing other podcasts i think podcast
gave a lot of like i i i worked in hot
in in los angeles and hollywood for a
long time and i'd never really found
some footing in television and stuff i
felt like
especially as they started to like
really move away from like
you know regular guys i'm not even like
a real redneck guy but i think they
immediately you're from the south so i'm
from louisiana yeah so but i think i
they they there just weren't a lot of
opportunities and i think that's what
podcasting has done it's kind of just
giving opportunities for regular guys
not to have to use like these vehicles
of hollywood yeah the agents and the
yeah and all the things yeah yeah and
there's there's so many talented people
out there now yeah and there's so many
vehicles like you're saying now of
people getting their talent out there
and letting people know and and doing
all those things which i mean it's a
good thing yeah it's interesting i mean
it kind of puts the power a lot of in
your own hands absolutely and
and even i thought about like i have
friends that like get cancelled or
whatever and it only helps these days
it's almost like if you
you want to get cancer if you schedule
your canceling well dude you're freaking
you're gonna go to the top you're morgan
wallin and ernest and hardy they're
gonna be on tour for the next 20 years
oh yeah they're fine yeah they're never
gonna they're fine dude when morgan's
bus leaves town it will never come back
just gonna keep rolling
with or without him it's gonna go to the
next with or without him bro they may
need a hologram after a couple
he's never he's gonna have a he's gonna
have a double here soon
he really should man
this is a singing double just put a hat
on his sunglasses that's a really good
idea for him actually
um
i've tried to get cancelled on like
instagram and stuff i don't
i don't know i don't know if i don't
know
i think you have to go really bad these
days yeah which i don't want to do that
but yeah my friend eric andre he's a
comedian and he had a show that was
going on television or a movie and he
just put a completely naked picture of
himself does that get you cancelled i
feel like that it got his account
canceled but it helped him but it helped
yeah definitely like yeah nude is i mean
that's obviously one way to go i don't
know if that's for me i wouldn't do it
kind of my hips kind of run right into
my stomach and it's do they yeah it's
just not
maybe work maybe maybe like work out for
a month and just like get jacked up and
then do it that's the blood of like a
like a
i kind of have the butt of like a would
you do a frontal or from behind
or a side oh i can't do side bro the way
i look from the side it's not good
you've thought about this a few times i
mean this is the most i've thought about
it with another man in the room you know
but um
i don't know it's a good question even
though sports illustrated issues where
everybody's like semi-naked in there and
like yeah
solos hiding their tits behind their
frisbees they're like 98 naked yeah and
they're or they have paint on
yeah that's
that's that's art though you could just
say it's art yeah you're right
if you say art like you're good
i'm expressing my my my body in in an
artistic way that's direction i put a
pride flag in the back and just say hey
homie this is art dude you know
i feel like you put a if you add in like
an that like an extra element of like
like a group that's kind of um an outlet
not like an outlier group but a group
that like you know struggles to find
their footing a lot of times i feel like
that kind of can give you like a carte
blanche sometimes
yeah sometimes but if you talk about it
before in this way and then do it you're
probably it probably won't work yeah
that's true so i i think you're kind of
screwed now what would you go you think
if you had to do a new would you go side
would you go because side your wiener's
gonna peek out the front a little yeah
hopefully yeah hopefully yeah i mean or
yeah i mean you want to put that
that body part in its best light i think
if you're going to do it yeah
so
i don't know that's a tough question
and if i did front maybe i would do
something else to like take away take
away from that yes
yeah maybe like a cool hat or something
anything maybe that's something i don't
know what i would do just like hey look
at this look at this don't look at that
just peek at that but look at this
yeah maybe something like that
um
when you did do you notice with reality
tv reality tv is very scary to me it's
an interesting thing i feel like it that
that is a world that really digs and
tries to forget like and gets really
manipulative um
do you uh
do you think that reality tv like
do you think that being a celebrity and
being married in like in a celebrity
kind of relationship is that a lot more
pressure on a marriage than you think a
regular marriage or do you think it's
just kind of grandfathered in after time
and you get the
hang of it um i think i think it can go
either way i think it definitely puts
pressure um
on the relationship because you you want
it to be portrayed a certain way on film
and that and that might not be reality
and i think that's where it gets a
little little little
fuzzy because
you know you're you're doing this on
television and then like you know it
it's rainbows and sunshine and like
that's not really real life for the most
part like you know there's highs and
stuff but like
real life can be
married in real life like it there's a
lot of boring times it just is what it
is like you can't always be
you know riding sky high yeah um
after a certain point it's like all
right you know you're married and it's
just
you know we're just we're living
together you're just sitting around
you're just waiting for you're sitting
in the car waiting for your wife to get
in the car yeah i mean you go to dinner
like you can do fun stuff but like
there's other times where it's like yeah
we're just
we're just living life like it's just
it's another it's another wednesday yeah
yeah sebastian maniscalco does on his
instagram he does a lot of uh waiting
for his wife yeah i love his instagram
yeah his is almost like that that to me
a lot of times feels like a real reality
show absolutely it's him like stumbling
through the packages at the door and
like being like which one of these and
that's like real everyday life yeah um
so yeah i mean reality tv it's it's
painting a picture that
isn't always necessarily true um
and i think it kind of skews the
audience a little bit but i mean that's
what reality tv is there for you know
it's fair for drama or for
whatever you know all all those things
yeah yeah i mean i think about why some
of it i look at i think i i want to just
sometimes i i remember
especially when i was like kind of
growing up i guess or maybe
like i've made a little bit of money but
i'm not i'm not like a real rich guy but
i remember i wanted to see some of the
kardashians because i wanted to see what
it was like if somebody was rich you
know sure like if they had like
you know indoor pets like that kind of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
you want to see what people are doing
you know i remember that
but um
do you feel like it can do you feel like
that had any effect on like your real
you got your relationship and i'm not
trying to get any relationship but do
you feel like that like
that can rat like
i just don't i'm really untrustworthy of
that kind of stuff so even the side
effects of a lot of that momentum and
what's glamour and stuff like that we
can start to believe it oh absolutely
yeah i mean and you start to you start
to believe it and you start to think um
that's how it should always be and you
know and you know it's the grass is
green on the other side like all those
things can someone can fall into that
trap um i didn't fall into it um
but it definitely could happen
and it's
you know and
reality tv doesn't bother me and i would
i'd go back and do it again for sure
and if someone came to me with an
awesome reality tv show idea i'd i'd do
it i mean i've got no issues with it
it's just i think you have to be really
grounded in kind of who you are and what
you want out of it right and and and
realize that hey this is this is a job
period
and and your life has to be in a stable
place and and you have to realize all
right when the cameras are gone like
it's just normal life again yeah
which i'm sure is hard for some people
yeah i would bet probably i mean i bet
it's almost like in some semblance the
same of like be you know doing football
or doing something for a long time and
then being out of this like yeah
but it's almost even different because
you're not you don't get to like
not hide behind a game but you you're
playing within a a vehicle football it's
not like it's you
standing out there like and you just
yell out some secrets at the line and
then you know the offensive lineman
turns around and tells you a secret you
know it's like but i mean people get
people get confused by this stuff
because it becomes their sense of self
like that's who they are right
and
that's what you do for a living that's
that's not what
that's not you that that you you if
you're if your validation is through
that stuff
that's eventually going to go away like
you're going to be lost and you know
some people it takes a little bit to
figure that out and find out like all
right how do i get validated you know
what who am i like what makes me
tick and yeah it's it's a
and i think that's pretty common for a
lot of people i'm sure within their jobs
and within kind of who they are yeah
yeah i could probably think that too man
um yeah i mean if your podcast is if
everything's gone tomorrow and you gotta
go down to wherever and work like it's
gonna be it's gonna be a different
experience like you're gonna be like oh
wait like it's all gone like that that
was kind of liquid death i was talking
on camera i was like where the lights at
yeah yeah that's a good point i i yeah
sometimes i think about that what would
i do sometimes what would you do
you know like they end podcast tomorrow
no one can do podcasts they outlawed
them they outlawed them yeah they put a
mask on all the cameras
[Laughter]
which they easily could
you know they do too they're two masks
just just in case um
that's a great question man i mean i do
stand up comedy for a living so i'd have
that but if that went if that went too
yeah
man i don't know i would probably
hopefully try to get myself a little bit
of land and maybe do
just become a prepper maybe a prepper
but also a prepper who has like a side
paintball type of biz maybe
maybe a pumpkin patch kind of like okay
for holidays yeah yeah something where
it's like at least around the holidays
people are going to come around to see
people see people okay so you're kind of
doomsday you're out for yourself but at
least around christmas yeah like holiday
time yeah it's gonna get a little
festive yeah yeah
and paintball you can work on some stuff
you know yeah you could locate see who
in town is exactly recruit yeah it's a
recruitment for you yeah yeah
like hey this guy
things go down you're on my team yeah
hey sam i want to talk to you about your
son over here he's a real uh yeah
he's got some potential in my world
when you're traveling to a destination
where you don't know the language it can
be challenging
to accomplish even the simplest of tasks
thankfully
there's babble
the number one selling language learning
app yep
through babel's bite-sized learning
lessons you'll learn new language skills
that you can actually use in the real
world from greetings menus and
directions to gaining a deeper
understanding of the culture
babble
that's trout that's travel essential
yep babel's 15-minute lessons make it
the perfect way to learn a language
they have all type of languages in there
you can get spanish french italian and
german baby right now when you purchase
a three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babbel.com
and use promo code theo that's
b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com
code
eo babel language for life
what's that
that's the beat getting beaten
in stockholm sweden that's where
urbanista was born in 2010
in stockholm sweden out of a love for
cities and urban life
urbanista
multi-sensory immersion without
compromise the sound the look the fit
the feel at an affordable price
yep urbanista headphones are inspired by
cities and urban lives in motion
you want that vibe you want that moving
forward you want that cutting edge you
want that stock home
around your freaking sound hounds your
ears
urbanista
drawing inspiration from great cities
rooted in scandinavian design don't
compromise and get all of this for
around half of what you pay for other
big name headphones yep
right now urbanista has a special offer
for this past weekend listeners
go to urbanista.com
theo to get 20 off your entire order
that's 20 off everything you'll even get
free shipping for all orders
over sixty dollars go to urbanista.com
theo for 20 off that's urbanista.com
theo
you want something new you want
something cutting edge you want sleek
design check it out
um
when you were when you when you when you
look at guys when you look at football
and you look at guys like what is some
what is it about
and i don't know if you're even able to
see you know what this would be like
what is it about a guy like tom brady
that makes him so
capable to pull it off yeah over time do
you notice it like do you
i mean i think it probably goes back to
his work at work ethic like this start
and then
you know he was he was in a great
situation yeah i mean i think you know
timing
situation work ethic um you know his
talent his brain like
a lot of things have to come together
like if you look at really successful
people um
you know they're obviously talented in
whatever their field is but there's
there's got to be some things that come
together to help them get to this point
yeah a team like a just a yeah and i
mean being with bill and and josh
mcdaniels and their defense was
unbelievable when he first got there and
obviously he was good too and he grew
with that and he became the team but
you know you look at a lot of these
quarterbacks that get into the league
early and they're just they're you know
they're on bad teams they don't have a
lot of talent around them um the coaches
are coaches kind of maybe getting fired
or coming in and starting over so
and not to take away from tom because i
mean what he's done is it will probably
never be done again um
you know but he would he came into a
really really good situation and and to
his credit he he took advantage of it
you know better than anybody could
is there like anything that he possesses
does it seem like he's magic when you're
around like when you see him or
something or is it just
well he's he's aging backwards right
yeah it is pretty pretty magnificent i
mean i think it is yeah i mean he's
benjamin button yeah he's benjamin brady
for sure
dude you know what's crazy benjamin
brady was my damn i had a principal in
school named benjamin brady really and
we should be able to get paddled yeah
bro and this dude
he would put it on you and then a friend
of mine died not too long ago this this
kid died or he's an adult now but he was
a kid when i when i met him because i
was a kid and
uh i went to his funeral and benjamin
brady was there dude beautiful yeah
and i hadn't seen him ever i'd only seen
him since he like paddled or something
like rude and he had a freaking uh he
was vape and i think and he was just
like chilling at his funeral it's so
different to see like people of like
authority whenever you're younger and
now like you're grown and you see them
now it's like you're just a regular just
a regular dude yeah you're eating
crackers
where's your paddle yeah
did you uh did do you guys have that
kind of corporal punishment when you
were in schools or no
you could get paddled really yeah did
you ever get it no no i was i was like
by the book um you know tried to i did
try to do everything right you did i was
that was the oldest and that i mean i
just that's just kind of what
i did
did you like were you like an instigator
at all in class you were like you were
just chill just chill yeah i mean i
didn't i mean no yeah and that that's
kind of how my oldest is now like he he
i was i was a pleaser you know like i
wanted to do the right thing i wanted to
i mean
towards the end of high school i stopped
caring so much about my grades and stuff
but like i went from like a's and b's to
like a c plus
a few classes yeah that's fun that
wasn't that fun that last year and a
half you like i think i'm gonna be okay
like i stopped i stopped taking like
honors english and i just went into like
the normal english class just english
and i was like this is awesome people
learning to stutter in there
i could do this yeah this yeah we went
from like 10 page papers to like just
write a paragraph please i'm like got it
just draw a picture anything
dude that was fun once you're in high
school and you kind of realize there's
that moment where it's like
you realize that the gr you don't have
those crazy grades that's going to do
anything for you yeah or you have a path
with a sport or with a
profession already and you're like oh
man and i think that's probably part
that's probably the part of the problem
like i figured out like this doesn't
matter right this isn't what i'm going
to be doing like i just need to get
through this part of it
obviously i don't want to be
disrespectful and you know just
absolutely bomb it but
a cb or a it's literally doesn't make a
difference right it's not going to make
a difference in my life yeah once you
learn that there's definitely like a new
found it's almost it's a little bit of
an apathy oh it's a letharg it's like a
freedom but it's also like uh
i'm going to take the
i'm going to do what i want to do now
kind of
yeah yeah and i think it's looked at
like you said it's looked at like you're
trying to take the easy way out but it's
like no i'm just i just i'm just gonna
focus my attention on something like
that matters to me now yeah instead of
something that matters to your teachers
or your parents or whatever
did you um we got a question right here
you want to bring this in sean your hair
looks like george washington do you see
that you see his haircut he does like
did you get it did you get it cut like
that
you're like hey
give me the choice give me that george
washington
they're probably the private the
barber's probably like who's that
that's patriotic dude it could be tommy
larry and gave him that cut dude
tommy cut your hair what if she did
haircuts and she only did cuts like
patriotic figures she only did president
cuts the first 16 presidents i'm gonna
give you the abe lincoln today yeah yeah
yeah we got that ben franklin a couple
ben franklin's here at noon oh let's
take forever
i go in that letter style me who cuts
your hair me i just started cutting my
own again man did you yeah
this lady named whitney cut it for a
while and this lady named libby cuts it
sometimes too like it's pulling off a
mullet is
i mean i couldn't do it i mean you do it
well thanks man
yeah i had this haircut when i was real
small and then i got like a man's cut
like a regular man yeah and i never felt
okay yeah this is a little bit more you
can hide kind of sure um i have a wide
nose so it's like this gives me a little
bit more more more more width yeah it
kind of makes it smaller yeah you got to
play it but now yeah but now that i look
at it it's not that wide now i think
some of it gets in your head too once
you start thinking one thing about
yourself yeah like oh man one of my legs
is too long or you know i got too much
hair on my body you don't say you start
going crazy
i do anyway
i just got a nordic track as well but um
why
i don't know i think they got me with
some of the adverts the advertisements
what is like a treadmill or like the
no not the hand too i'll do that later
down the line but it's just treadmill
so nordictrack makes a treadmill now
yeah make a treadmill but it's it has
like a click you get up to about 5.5 and
it starts it has a i think they got that
fast is that a walk i mean it's a it
might it's maybe it's a slow jog i mean
in the nfl it's probably a walk
but for me it's probably for a just a
regular you're getting it yeah i'm
getting in yeah
i'm cruising but um but it's not very
nordic like nor i feel like when they
say nordic that has like a
like an aspen like a switzerland vibe to
it and it has like a fan on it but it
doesn't even get that cold it's just
more for like comfort i think so it
doesn't i wish it had that blast you out
[ __ ] we're going down to 25 degrees
you know i'm saying good luck
[ __ ] came on the thing or
something you know i was i was uh
i saw in your garage i was poking around
your garage and where did you get your
cold tub oh yeah this company this new
company called blue cube i think
they sent it to me really it's their
first one blue blue coupe blue cube send
me one please yeah um i
probably will man i uh
wim hof yeah i like that wim off stuff
man i wish i focused on it a little bit
more i know i got into it when i was in
chicago three probably five years ago
and uh yeah i mean it's really good
stuff
it's really good stuff who was a player
you played with that was like way into
that kind of stuff you know that was
just like you know you know it was just
eating liver out of a bag all day on the
field you know
you know when i first i mean
nfl is weird it's really weird um
because it's it's very very rare to find
anybody that's into like alternative
stuff really yeah like these dudes are
just eating mcdonald's and i mean it's
gotten better but like
it's it's a it's a fast-paced
you know crush your body and just
go to the next day it's not really it's
not
i was never around a lot of guys that
were really focused on taking care of
their bodies i mean there's there's
obviously people out there but right
you know 75 percent of the guys are just
you know going to chick-fil-a or
mcdonald's or doing whatever and just
coming in and rolling damn and these
guys are unbelievable athletes like
these guys are programmed to play
football and they are absolute
freak shows damn so they can just they
they've obviously gotten used to being
able to do that they can yeah do they
can eat whatever they want drink
whatever they want and show up and just
absolutely
do it on sundays
what about smokers you ever because um
i'm friends with blake blake griffin and
uh he said that
uh he used to play with this cool guy
from slovakia that would smoke
cigarettes after the games yeah did you
ever play with anybody that smoked i
mean i played with guys that smoked weed
yeah i'm talking about cigarettes
i don't know i mean not that i know of
anybody that smokes cigarettes i don't
even know people that smoke cigarettes
yeah is that still a thing i don't know
they still sell cigarettes i mean i just
threw my vapes away because they just
made me nervous at night because i would
hit them too much and then i would get
all nervous but um wait what you vape or
not no
i think it's fun for a little while i
mean i i think like this nicotine
yeah it's nicotine yeah but it's
flavored it's like you can get like you
know berry crush you know
you know uh
you know fun lime or something i don't
know different type of flavor you need
to get like
pear
i don't get a pear party or this is a
different one you lost out here
um
oh there you go right there lynn dawson
enjoys a sweet sig during the super bowl
yeah they always put a cigarette in my
mouth in my pictures yeah i know they
got the smoking j stuff and i was just i
wouldn't even really think about that i
just wish you knew a player that
freaking smoked dude because that guy to
me would be a damn animal he likes just
smoked cigs yeah just [ __ ] whipped
just came into work yeah yeah chucked it
out and said let's do this voice yeah
yeah that now that to me like
chick-fil-a yeah i get it man i mean i
mean they they used to all smoke i mean
they used that there used to be a thing
yeah i mean drink beer and drink beer in
the locker rooms smoke cigarettes
yeah when i was in school man they had
um before
in louisiana you used to be able to
drink when you were 18 years old you
could buy alcohol and it was the last
one of the last states to be able to do
that because the federal government said
we're not going to give you any more
road money yeah they said we're we're
not going to give you money for roads
right yeah we're not going to be in the
first couple years we're like [ __ ] it we
don't need you guys
we have four wheelers we'll be fine yeah
we'll drink and we'll ride on a crocs
back you don't say we'll figure it out
but i think after about two years the
roads you realize people are drunk and
they're driving them bad yeah this is a
problem this doesn't work out
so you lost that battle yeah but it was
like a year two before i got to high
school they would have parties at the
school like on certain days where kids
would um just bring a keg and you would
have it like at if they were 18 they'd
be able to stay there and and party man
and i hear these great stories yeah and
it's like
sometimes i think the lore of things
makes me
like the nostalgia of things makes
things more exciting
yeah you know like that's like that
stuff and then like you know the 70s
when everything was like more innocent
yeah like i feel like the innocence of
the world is kind of gone
which is i mean it's unfortunate but i
mean there's other things in the world
that are amazing right now too but like
that innocence of being able to do those
things is is is i think it's long gone
yeah
yeah there's so much judgment now on
every little thing yeah you can't do
anything yeah i mean you don't even
smoke a cigarette in you and you're a
smoker i'm a smoker yeah that's crazy so
it's yeah people want me to sign like
packs of cigarettes for them i don't
know i don't even know like i don't
smoke cigarettes yeah i smoke a cigar
yeah
love a cigar did you ever go smoke a
cigar with michael jordan in chicago no
no um because he always smokes him it
seems like yeah i mean he would always
have him in the locker room and stuff i
feel like he smokes one daily yeah which
i don't know if that's good or bad
i think if i think if you're him you can
do it i feel like i think it's for
different people it's different things
you know like you know what you can
handle
you know i i mean yeah
six cigars a day okay i was way off
yeah that's a lot it seems like
i mean
that's a lot of i mean
is that that can't is that good for you
they see that nicotine would ramp my
heart up
and i couldn't and i would you don't
inhale a cigar but i mean i'm sure
something gets into you obviously yeah i
think some gets wet for me some would
definitely get into me
um yeah here we go negative effects of
cigars let's do this
cigar smoking okay can't mouth cancer
that's bad throughout cancer probably
bad too
lung cancer heart disease
all bad things all pretty infertility
i'm done having kids so i'm cool with
that yeah then you're ready yeah yeah
i got no issues with that one that's
what you could come out with then uh
cutler's infertility cigars
only smoke if you never want to have
children again yeah
colors chakra shockers realignment and
infertility cigars dude i think that
place would be packed oh gosh we'd be on
fire you put a porch out front people
would go forever lying out the door
um
yeah i was thinking like uh
was there a big like because for like a
regular like i i would be remember being
in the stands during high school when
kids were playing dude and i played
basketball but not super well yeah and
i just remember
does it seem more fun at college or at
the pros is there like a big change
where the
what what's some of that change in there
because one has so much more money
attached to it one has a lot like that
all-american type of thing yeah um was
there one you even preferred more than
the other high school high school is the
purest form
you know you're you're out there you're
playing with your friends and your guys
and you're like you're just you're
playing football just because you love
it yeah uh
college i think was college is fun
because it's college
you're away from your parents you're
living life you're at parties you play
football you're going to school like
you're becoming an adult
and you know you're figuring out life at
that point yeah
and then i think the nfl it becomes it's
a job
and
you know there's supplies some you get
jaded by it a little bit and it's
literally a job right and the first
couple years you you it's a blast
because you're having fun you have money
um stadiums you buy your own house you
can buy a car
but after a while like it's it is it
there's a job attached to that and
you're expected to perform and if you
don't perform you know somebody else
will take your job so like
it's it's a little bit different yeah
that is interesting i never thought like
what if i had a job but there's somebody
sitting over there who if i'm not doing
my job good today they can come back
well and then there's you know 50 people
in the room being like critiquing like
everything you do i mean you people
critique you but i mean
it's just different i mean every monday
tuesday
in the facility like they're bringing
guys in to try out i mean they're out
there on the field like running running
routes throwing doing drills
every monday and tuesday damn so i mean
there's there's you know there's a
percentage of the locker room that kind
of gets turned over every couple weeks
yeah i never thought about that with
that pressure but like even if i'm on
stage doing a stand-up and there's
somebody off in the wings who's over
there stretching
just waiting yeah please mess up please
mess up please mess up um put me in
coach god that would be crazy man that's
intense we got a question that came in
right here from someone this isn't live
just so you know
what up this is colton out here in las
vegas i had a question for jay
what was the worst part of your rookie
hazing and then what was the stupidest
thing you spent on your first contract
money gang gang gang baby
um
worst part of hazing um i was lucky i
was really lucky i went to denver and it
was john lynch champ bailey jake plummer
al wilson it was an old veteran team and
mike shanahan was a coach and like it
was just it was ran
really well
you know guys were respectful guys were
cool you know they messed with you
but like they did it the right way right
like you look at you look around today
and like guys are getting their head
shaved and doing all and doing stuff
like it wasn't like that all we had to
do was get in front of the team and
either sing a song or tell a joke right
and that was it
we were done did you hear stories like
old days when it was like really crazy
because
it kind of reminded me i guess of like
in fraternities and stuff you'd always
hear crazy stuff like in lsu you're
crazy yeah in college we
they blindfolded us
and then we had to run through the
locker room
and they they had wiffle ball bats and
all kinds of stuff and just like beat us
as we ran through it
and then we got to
we got to the finish line and
uh we had to swallow a goldfish oh damn
really yeah
and they threw us in the showers and all
the showers were on cold and they just
threw us in there and like made us wait
in there oh wow interesting like yeah
like that like yeah we didn't have any
of that stuff
i mean that's a really bad i mean yeah
you had to carry pads and stuff like
that off the floor the lord will fix
that is that tebow yeah oh he'll be fine
but yeah that's a bad cut it looks cool
on him though he does kind of look cool
yeah he pulled it off yeah i think it
reminds me of moe and curly and larry of
the threes that's exactly what it is i
mean but if you just wear a hat it's
like alright i'm good
yeah
but once you don't wear that hat dude
you're definitely you better have a wife
yeah you might as well just not wear a
hat just so like it's it's known yeah
like you don't want to take it off and
be like oh wait a second yeah you don't
want to surprise people and i don't
think he was looking for a wife at that
point either so he's probably good i
think this might have been a point i
don't remember in his career when he i
don't even know if he was because i
think he had some stuff where he wasn't
maybe dating i don't remember yeah like
he was a virgin and stuff the whole
thing right yeah so i think yeah he was
well now this dude right there
that looks like his actual haircut
he was like this is this is you don't
even have to cut my hair
this is our roll yeah
this guy looks like he got cancer from
like a native american like this dude
looks like
he is frickin
all in bro like last of the chemotherapy
dude this dude's ready to ride bro i'm
with this guy man
um oh my goodness is the biggest uh you
had a lot of neat uh people to play with
over there was matt forte a really cool
guy yeah matt's the best god i was a big
j.p loseman fan growing up yeah uh and i
went to school i went to school at
loyola when jp went to tulane and so i
got to know him some and so um yeah
super super super talented um awesome
dude in the locker room off the field
like did everything right um
true professional he was awesome yeah
the offensive lineman is that your most
important guys like do you have to like
for me yeah yeah i mean receivers are
important too but like you know
something like you just gotta kind of
you throw in the ball take them to
dinner like
they're kind of devish so like they're
easy to deal with i mean the offensive
lineman like they
they make or break you is there some
times where you really were on seasons
and where it's like man i don't know if
these some of these guys are really down
for me like is there is there is there
like a real thing when those guys are
like down for you and when they're not
yeah i mean you you've got to start the
you guys are in the pre they're in
training camp like you've got to earn
their trust and you've got to be there
for them and you got to you know stick
up for them and go to dinners with them
and like
ride or die like they're your co-workers
yeah they're
they're your front line yeah
so even if they mess up like you you got
to build them back up it makes me scared
bro i'll get scared even watching people
now is the time to celebrate
you know jay cutler's play in the nfl
and draftkings is rocking the nfl
that's right the first nfl sunday of the
season is about to kick off
and draftkings is the official fantasy
partner
download the draftkings app now and use
code theo
this week new customers can get a free
shot at the one million dollar top prize
and compete for millions in prizes
across all contests enter code t-h-e-o
to get a free shot at the one million
dollar top prize with your first deposit
that's code theo only at draftkings the
official daily fantasy partner of the
nfl minimum five dollar deposit
eligibility restrictions apply see
draftkings.com for details
that's right you get a free shot at one
million dollars
i'll tell you this autumn is in the air
it's autumn time it's time for autumn
and you know it and uh
and you want to trim your pumpkins man
you want to trim your pumpkin patch but
you don't want to nip your nads baby you
know what i'm saying i'm here to make
sure that you take care of your body to
the fullest
and i'm talking about you know what i'm
talking about god bless you manscaped
yep manscaped
get it take care of your body cut things
well but don't cut off any parts you
need it's time to bundle up with the
manscape performance package 4.0
inside this package
you'll find a lawnmower 4.0 trimmer that
weed wacka
ear nose and hair trimmer
and the crop preserver crop reviver and
boxer briefs that's right
yep the fourth generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their advanced skin safe technology
yep get 20 off in free shipping and
support the podcast by going to
manscape.com t-h-e-o for 20 off and free
shipping that's 20 off and free shipping
by going to manscape.com
theo make your body your balls your
pumps
ken's a priority
i heard you say that it seems like
easier for quarterbacks like
quarterbacks don't get hit as much these
days do you think it is that way do you
think like the game is getting more like
just um almost to a two-hand touch for
quarterbacks in a way
yeah i mean yeah when they're they're
protecting the the most valuable asset
out there i mean these guys are getting
paid
crazy amount of money so
the nfl is going to protect them and
you know i don't think i think i think i
think it's a good thing for the game
because like you don't want to get into
a season where you know you lose five of
the best starting quarterbacks in nfl
like you want like they're they're
trying to take care of the product they
want to put a good product out there
they want to make it exciting
you know it's just uh you know it's a
fine line it's like hey like how far do
you actually go here with this
interesting
um
what feels some of your time these days
man so obviously you started potting
were you doing something else was there
another business that you thought about
getting into
um you know
have people come at you with some weird
ideas or anything you know i'm doing a a
meat subscription box now called yeah
yeah so i'm doing that
and and that was fun i thought about
doing a butcher shop at one point but
i'm like i don't know if that's i mean
butcher shop would be cool i know but
they like you know the pandemic or hit
and i was like well people aren't even
leaving their houses like they're
definitely not gonna go buy meat yeah
that's true yeah yeah
hey we can't leave our house but we
gotta go buy some meat today let's do
that
because the wife's like no you're not
going you're not going out we need meat
damn it i'm going to go to the butcher
shop but cuddles selling meat
um and then yeah i mean i don't know i'm
just figuring it out yeah no do you feel
any pressure you don't need financial
you don't need no i don't feel i don't
feel pressure um i like doing the
podcast stuff you know the kids are
getting older so they're doing more
stuff
um
you know there was pressure when i first
got out but i mean that's gone now so
it's just kind of just
i've i always said like hey like things
will start to come like i'll i mean i'm
not gonna just sit on my my butt forever
and i'm not doing that so yeah it's it's
it's picking up yeah
um did you get to play against drew
brees you guys played once right in the
playoffs maybe played in the playoffs
when they had reggie bush i think the
saints had reggie bush oh no i was i was
in chicago that i played uh
i played him in den i played him in
denver um put him in denver they had
reggie and then in chicago we played him
probably i'm sure we played him a couple
times was it interesting to see drew
brees because he almost is like an
anomaly like i remember when i first got
to new orleans
he came out and saw a comedy show it was
like his first week in town and scott
vegeta brought him out to see a comedy
show one time yeah we won that game
that denver denver saints game
they missed a field goal they missed a
like a 50-yard field goal 40-yard field
goal at the at the end to lose and we
won
um
yeah he's
yeah it's it's was and
if you watch him like he lifts his head
up because he's short he lifts his head
up and like he's looking through his
face mask
and i'm like i don't know no idea how
it's like insane and he's insanely
accurate insanely smart
um
it's yeah
he's got a ton of records i mean he's
gonna he's people have a hard time
catching him
was it fun to hand the ball off and not
have to pass that's what i would want to
do i feel like oh sometimes kind of
relaxing like yeah like yeah like just
you know you don't even have to think
but i mean a lot of the run players have
checks on them you've got to go the
other way you've got to point a mic i
mean there's
very few like we call them uh call and
runs like just car plays like you just
go up there you call it and you just go
up there and say hey blue 80 bloody set
up and you just hand it off
and there's a handful of those in the
game plan but i mean not many there's
probably fewer in today's game than i
had
did you ever hand it off to a gun you're
like man this guy is [ __ ] dude they're
gonna kill this guy oh yeah that's
awesome yeah you handed off me like this
is going nowhere
good luck bro
good luck
damn bro that's freaking wild man
um
you had that thing a couple weeks ago
they were talking about the mask with
the kids yeah and the superintendent or
the would you really be a superintendent
i'd be on the school board i'm going to
be i want to be on the school board um
i would vote for you man i would help
you campaign i appreciate it uh
in my district it's not i can't
run until 2024.
so what is it 20 why because you have to
live there for a long time no just
because like that's how the terms are so
i think it's a four year term i think
i'm guessing and
the last vote was in 2000 so the guy in
my district isn't up until 2024. so i've
got some time to uh campaign hit the
road fundraiser
all the things you yeah maybe do a
little comedy cuts fundraiser absolutely
some meat some chuckles get some uh get
some uh some school moms out there yeah
but it's it's people have been
supportive um and you know williamson
county i think is going through it right
now with the mass situation and
everything else and
it's uh
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens in the school systems down there
yeah it's kind of it's it's kind of wild
thinking about like kids having to wear
that's kind of almost the scariest thing
i feel like some people say well kids
don't know it's an issue if you don't
tell them it's an issue
and some of that i get but also like
i feel like if i have a mascot i can't i
don't get the same feelings from people
i don't get the same intuition yeah and
also it's like children are like the
least like
it just seems it seems ridiculous yeah
and you and i mean now you know that's
what they're spinning now if you go on
cnn like it's like all right you know
we've got
outrageous number of kids getting
getting sick and stuff and then if you
go to a different site it's like well
they're
you know the survival rate for kids is
99.9 percent so it's it's like you get
it from both sides yeah and and my and
you know i got pinned on the no mass
side which i'm fine with that and that's
for my kids i don't want them to wear
masks in school yeah i think it's it's
hard enough being in school
it's hard enough you know going through
that you know that k through five to
have to have a mask on and
learn how to read and write and talk and
do all this stuff
with that being said like if you want to
send your kid to school with a mass
that's that's on you yeah i'm fine with
it i got no issues if you want to get
the vaccine get the vaccine yeah um i
just don't think we we can make a
mandate for you know k through five like
hey you have to wear a mask that was my
whole thing like you can't mandate that
right and then and then and they and
they they gave they gave everyone you
can opt out i mean they they figured
that part out so i mean we opted out
um
but i i just don't want to get pinned
like all right i'm a hundred percent
against this and i'm i'm guessing for my
own being
but if you have a different opinion i'm
i'm more than willing to listen and i'm
more than willing to support whatever
decision you want to make
yeah totally i think it's interesting
sometimes how if you say anything that
is even like contrary or not even
contrary but like it's like if you want
to raise your hand and even talk about
stuff
you immediately get pinned on like
you're this outlier you're this like
anarchist and i think a lot of that is
goes back to what we're talking to
earlier it's just like anything that
people can click on it's like they just
want that's all they care about making
they don't really care about making a
conversation and it's and it's all just
you extreme over here extreme over here
like there's no
like middle ground anymore there's no
common sense like i don't understand i
think there are a lot of them but those
people no one wants to well and they
don't want to talk those people don't
want to talk because you're going to get
destroyed on one side of the other but i
think you're right i think there's a lot
of people in this middle ground
that do have common sense that do want
to live in this middle area and don't
want to be on these
extremes they just
you know i mean it's not worth it
anymore to say anything yeah it's like
that's the weird part i'm not going to
say anything i don't want to deal with
this either side of this
yeah man sometimes i get afraid to speak
up man about certain things yeah but
also sometimes i get afraid this is why
i get afraid jay because sometimes i
um
we give him another water just so he has
it thank you sean um sometimes i get
afraid because i just don't i sometimes
my brain doesn't work as well as as fast
as i need it to so it's like i don't
want to say something until i know
exactly what it is and people don't give
you room to like
oh no you say one thing wrong it's over
yeah dude you don't get a second chance
it's like well that's impossible so the
only people that are even allowed to
speak anymore then are people reading
off teleprompters who are knowing
exactly what they're about to say or
maybe like ben shapiro who's like
somehow or jordan peterson who are like
computers and they're able to get it
from here together process it just like
that it's crazy man seeing some of that
and there's a lot of people out there
that just don't want to say anything
because they don't want to get canceled
they don't want to lose sponsors they
don't want to lose their job so like
they're just like hey i can't say
anything yeah i can't because i've got
to feed my family i need to go to work
yeah and that's kind of interesting too
it's like at least yeah maybe sometimes
i'll take that for granted like i'm in a
place where at least i could say some
stuff if i want to but i worry though if
i say like not say certain things but
like
like the other day we did a netflix
special and that we taped at the ryman
and they
like a couple days before like everybody
needs to be vaccinated or have a
negative test sure
and it was like
you know everybody had bought their
tickets knowing that they either had a
just knowing both things i'm willing to
go i've been vaccinated i'm willing to
go and i haven't yeah
um
so that was really interesting because
then it's like this
they're like well this is kind of our
production that we're putting on so it's
like you want to work with the rules
people have already bought their tickets
they're coming you want them to be able
to be a part of it and see the show
but it's interesting when businesses
kind of um
start to have mandates and whether
they're worried about what the social
media repercussions will be
and that's that's so real that's a
that's the world we live in now i know
it's weird man it is weird it's really
weird and we're at the point to we're at
that we're at that we're still i think
in that period where we're navigating
what that is and what it means and if it
means anything like
you know two years ago a tweet somebody
said something it meant everything and
now it's starting to be a little bit
like people don't even pay attention
that much no yeah yeah i mean twitter i
think twitter like
it's just about quantity like people are
just spitting out stuff i mean and it's
just gone like there's a next thought
the next thought the next thought
um yes i don't think twitter i mean
there's impactful people that tweet for
sure but like i think a lot of twitter
is just
it's just you know it's garbage yeah
it's just a weird chatterbox it's like
yeah it's almost like stephen a smith
but in like a business yeah just just
firing off stuff yeah just right just
word garbage
anything that it's like anything that
will pick up steam exactly but it's
gonna be it's gonna be interesting like
10 years from now like we look back in
the space and time and like what
what we're going to think about
i don't know i don't want to speculate
but it's going to be it's going to be
it's going to be interesting
because you know you look back at
remember like like y2k yeah oh yeah that
was like the first big thing yeah like
it the world was ending like banks banks
were gonna be like finished people were
buying lambs dude people were buying
like lambs and stuff for [ __ ] you know
saying people are insane yeah banks were
going to be done yeah all your money
will be going
on
like the whole thing i wonder if that
was like the first thing that really
started to scare people i don't know i
don't know but i mean you're gonna be a
prepper here soon so like you're good oh
dude
i can't wait bro i'll be just sitting
there with a kindle [ __ ] watching old
joe rogans
just doing all i can man
just eating [ __ ] jay cutler beef
jerky that gets brought to me
from a local wagon what was that
question that came in man we'll get to a
couple questions here for you jay
hi theo and jay um i am so excited to
know that jay is going to be on theo's
podcast that's awesome
jay
oh my gosh learn everything you can from
him he's awesome uh my question is for j
cutler
um my son started playing football this
year he's nine he's a big boy and i'm
wondering what some of your encouraging
words might be for a first time football
player first year um and anything for
the moms out there who are watching our
uh sweet little thick boys getting
blasted on the line
gang uncut
oh that's tough i know i know whenever
my mom like when i started playing
football and even like whenever i got
into the nfl like she was an absolute
nightmare on yesterday
oh my gosh so nervous i mean literally i
mean
every game i played
just terrified
and what is he terrified are you getting
hurt yeah getting hit like a whole thing
and
would she be in the stands always at the
same spot kind of where you could see
her um
yeah i mean i always knew where our
parents were and then we had a box
when i got an nfl so i mean i always
knew where they were
um
and looking back on it now i'm like i
get it because i have kids right
and they my oldest ones play football
and it's like
i don't know bro like
i don't know like i don't know if we
need to put you out here this because i
mean watching them get hit and stuff
it's like
it it's gonna it's it's hard and i took
it for granted as whenever i was playing
like i didn't get it you know i got it
but i was like hey i'm gonna be fine
like i've got this taken care of like
you can chill out mom yeah um
yeah you don't get what they're going no
not at all but now you see them now yeah
now i see it completely different i'm
like i'm like i i understand it now like
it
and thinking about
cam or my oldest like going out there
playing football and getting you know
just smoked on a place like gosh that's
gonna be tough to watch
and would people try and smoke him or
other dads gonna put a hit you know gosh
yeah yeah lions fans or something you
know some dads and lions yeah it's gotta
be tough absolutely in any household
absolutely and it's just you know that
undue pressure on them and you know all
those things so
i'm sorry to all the all the moms out
there i know how how difficult it is to
to do that and you just gotta
encourage your son as much as you
possibly can positive positive positive
it's in any sport when they first start
make it fun make it fun oh make it fun
what sport if you had to lead him into a
different one do you think you'd maybe
lead him into baseball oh yeah huh yeah
i mean
baseball's safe man yeah super safe i
mean obviously you can get hit with a
ball um
the only the only downside of baseball
is you play 162 games oh yeah your
wife's gonna leave you oh for sure
you might even know she's gone dude how
many games you just come back like
wait what where are you going where'd
you go
um i'm friends with walker bueller
actually that went to vanderbilt he's
probably him and joe musgrove are
probably my only two baseball guys
that's pro baseball men that i know but
um yeah it's a different lifestyle
but one thing that's interesting about
him dude he's kind of uh i don't want to
see he's not a regular size dude but he
throws just out of sheer fury bro like
some guys are like six seven you know
but i mean he throws out of just his
whole body still actually
dude in one of his arms when you see him
he showed me one time it's like way
longer yeah yeah his whole right side of
his body is probably completely
different and that's that's typical of
um quarterbacks too like
yeah i mean this this side is is is
doing this and this side is pulling so
like you're pushing and you're pulling
um so i mean you get torts i mean you're
doing this all day long so i mean it has
effects on your body
what about a ufc do you ever you ever
been to it yeah love it you do yeah i
went to uh connor's last fight connor
and dustin yeah me too dude yeah
me too i was there i saw corey feldman
there did you yeah which is pretty cool
who else oh i saw
i got to meet austin hooper okay um
who's a football guy and baker mayfield
and obj
they're actually really cool yeah i saw
them uh friday night met trump saturday
night before the fight yeah no was that
cool it was really cool
that's gonna get me canceled
meet nick chuck huh meeting nick chubb
who you met nick chubb donald trump oh
you met trump yeah oh yeah no i don't i
mean i don't think that'll get you
canceled dude i think you can meet
i mean i think you're probably probably
fine dude i was there when he came into
the arena the place went
it went crazy yeah went crazy the place
went berserker they were chanting for
him yeah that was wild man um but that
was the first time i've ever been around
um you got to meet him though huh yeah
first time i've ever been around a
president um and like secret service are
they there oh yeah they were there they
look legit or they don't look legit
that's a really good question i've heard
mixed reviews sometimes and it was mixed
reviews and i was with my buddies
and we were sitting there and
we're like we're kind of i don't know i
mean i probably shouldn't say this but
we will i will we're kind of sizing up
the secret service not that we're gonna
do anything but it's like all right you
know like these guys are they should be
the best the best i was
in in the
security world and you're at a ufc even
people everybody size in every yeah but
i mean we're at the trump we're the
trump hotel at this point okay we're in
this you know conference room just
waiting oh you're waiting to see him
yeah we're waiting to see him and secret
service is around and i'm like you know
what like he looks legit right you know
you're five seven yeah just kind of
looks like a normal dude below normal
two inches yeah yeah and i'm like i just
don't
but i mean they have to be super trained
and let's ask my buddies like do you
think you could take that guy
and he's like
probably he goes if i train for a year i
could take that guy like no weapon
a year is a long time
now especially when you don't have any
time because but i think these dudes
these guys these guys they've got some
they've got some skill set that that we
don't know about that i don't think you
can you prepare for in a year
yeah that's probably true
yeah i think you're looking at guys who
are probably retired seals that sort of
thing yeah or like some bad dudes yeah
and like i've thought about that like
you know you run into like
mma guys are everywhere now it's like if
you you you you just got to be careful
with people
that is kind of a cool equalizer of
things it's like i don't i mean i'm not
a fighter so i don't fight people yeah
but like i know people that do and like
if you run into the wrong dude in a bar
like it could go real bad real fast yeah
it used to be totally different you used
to be kind of like oh you know this guy
will win this yeah but now it's like
yeah with all these headlocks leg locks
kimuras these chokes just break your arm
in like two seconds and just walk out
yeah dude i go over to nashville mma or
i i did actually tell i got a couple of
cracked ribs and it was a really
affecting my workflow yeah but um rips
would do that to you yeah huh
that's just disheartening man it sucks
everything you can't you can't function
you can't do anything i could barely
even hug somebody if i wanted to it you
can't even take a [ __ ] yeah
yeah i couldn't even i almost had to
keep my hands up like this when i should
do which is insane but it was just like
less pressure on my body i get it
god man the stuff that men go through
women think they go through it all
the stuff that men go they go through
some stuff i mean yeah that's a good
point you're right dude you're right
dude um who was your first girlfriend do
you remember in high school did you have
one um
first first real girlfriend yeah her
name was brooke yeah
she's pretty hotter now i mean yeah i
felt like at the time dude i bet you
always got the hot ones man
dude i remember i had to make out with
this girl in a sand trap that had two
different color eyes dude so was it like
cool two different colors or like kind
of did it freak you out
it was a little wizard it was little
dungeons and dragons you know what i'm
saying like a little bit somebody's
rolling one of those big
what i'm saying every time you looked at
her really cool chick though yeah so
but yeah man i remember one time the hot
girl for some reason
i got she she was down to go to like a
dance or something she was feeling her
vibe yeah i don't know what happened she
might have not been feeling well yeah i
don't know what happened but anyway she
was giving me a chance she was ill yeah
yeah
and we went to
uh oh and we went to like this dance
and then i we were back at my friend's
place where i was staying at and i like
ha she were like kind of kissing and i
just couldn't believe in my head that
this hot girl was giving me an
opportunity yeah so i'm like i'm just
like i'm just not doing real well
there's a statue oh dude i'm trying to
kiss but i can't like open get my mouth
you're overthinking it oh dude i'm
overthinking just like you know i've got
brains in every part of my body every
and then i remember trying to like touch
her panties and stuff and i got so
nervous dude that i just took her home
bro
and i remember dude i remembered she got
out of the car
and even she was shocked like why am i
going yeah what's happening here yeah
and i remember pulling over by this
freaking
this dock this boat dock and [ __ ]
crying in my car dude and that was in
high school that sucks it was like my
own nerves made it so hard for me to
like sometimes do things like
even someone's playing basketball like
if they ever put me at point guard i'd
be so nervous i couldn't handle i would
just shoot it from half court
like you just didn't want to mess it
yeah just like yeah i just get it out of
my hands so i was like if i do this you
know then i'm okay you're good yeah
but everything man that's how i that's
why i think do you i feel like
quarterbacks have to have just not have
this nerve thing you know you you i mean
yeah i mean i got nervous i mean i
always got nervous before games but i
think it was more like an anxious type
of thing of like all right i'm ready to
do this like let's go do this like um
there you know didn't want to fail and i
know there's guys out there that
are are scared of failing um
and there was probably no though i
probably had some of that in me i know
it definitely had some that in high
school um
but i think once i got to the nfl like
you prepare and like you do everything
during the week so like you give
yourself the best opportunity on sunday
to be ready and if you do that like
you're good
but like there is of
definitely a factor of the unknown out
there like you're not sure like is this
gonna work am i gonna perform am i going
to
be good enough on on this given day um
and and there's definitely those
thoughts that run through your brain for
sure and in my brain anyway yeah
um
was that you the first girl you ever
kissed brooke
no i kissed a different i kissed a girl
before that christy yeah dude before
that
at a dance the girl that i kissed was
named christy bro really i'm not even
joking dude and i would say her last
name but
and she had part of her toothless kind
of chip she kind of had that lloyd
christmas a little you know
and somebody locked us in a room dude
some pervert i think
and why and like went out by the window
and watched us stay in there and try to
kiss louisiana is a different place man
it was happening so weird
maybe that's why i was always so scared
it was just everything was [ __ ]
there's so many perverts
it's a different it's a different state
uh was it at a dance or was it yeah yeah
it was yeah yeah
yep i mean school dances where i mean
you look back on them now and it's like
there was so much pressure
in it
yeah it's like who am i gonna dance with
like you you're gonna sit on the
sidelines are you gonna get in the mix
like what's happening here yeah and all
the slow songs were so good back then is
so long
oh yeah
yeah that's for a good time do they
still have school dances is that still a
thing i don't know it might be virtual
now i'm sure probably
and i think if you're erect you just
like press a button or it's like you
know what i'm saying like kind of pings
your screen or whatever
um
dude that's funny but you got nervous
too even asking girls out and stuff for
sure yeah really yeah yeah yeah
god dude yeah absolutely can't even
believe that yeah i mean i was i mean i
was kind of a late bloomer
in in school so and like i don't think i
i mean you were tall though right no oh
you weren't
i mean i was i mean i was taller than
you yeah but like i i grew up probably
i grew an inch and a half in college oh
damn my freshman year
because the tall guy had always i feel
like the tall guy always is such a weird
thing if you don't play a sport yeah
then you got to work at the airport
usually by the baggage do something and
it's like if there's not like so to be
tall because you're standing out from
the crowd and to not have like a
maybe a skill or something that makes
you feel comfortable that would be scary
yeah like if you were like six foot nine
and like you didn't play basketball it's
like what are you doing bro yeah
what do you do with your life at least
move to slovakia and play like on the
internet you know oh gosh um let's get
one or two more questions did you um
was there uh man there was a
oh were there players in the nfl do you
think that couldn't read like is it that
uh yeah absolutely wow what a doubt
i don't know how many but i'm i'm
positive there are students i can't read
that's awesome
that's awesome well i mean the nfl is
like it's just i mean
it's probably
the
nfl players they come from different
backgrounds in basketball or baseball or
soccer i mean a lot of these kids from
like come from you know some tough tough
areas oh yeah out of florida and texas
and stuff and
you know
football is their way out yeah and you
know reading and writing is
i i'm sure it's less now than what what
it used to be just because the education
and
i mean social media like they all have
social media so they probably all can
read it right now i'm probably wrong
no i think by i think now you're
probably right i mean i remember we had
kids at our school definitely that were
in eighth grade that couldn't read them
right you know it was like
what's common in louisiana i feel like
yeah i think it is yeah it's part of our
that's our national that's part of your
charm
our national anthem is just a bunch of
people just
staring at the alphabet our state our
state song
here's a question right here from the
guy from friday night lights after he uh
after things went took a different turn
here we go
hi theo hi jay
hope this finds you guys well he's
excited my question to jay is you know
we hear a lot of stories about how nba
players and nfl players
they go broke within like three years of
being out of their respective leagues
and i know that's not the case with you
jay but i would be interested in knowing
what your best investment has been with
your with your nfl money and also what
your worst investment has been with your
nfl money i know theo was asked to be an
investor in like a mexican drug cartel
zoo or something which
it's in a load could have been a cash
cow
a little risky but could have been a
cash cow well it burned down just about
a month ago
whole zoo burned down
really yeah me and my buddy gotta be
kind of cool to own a zoo
oh i think it would be good like on a
lion or cutler's cages
yeah yeah i don't feel oh man the cages
probably aren't a good look though
um best for soft cages soft cages yeah
yeah
i could see that padded yeah yeah i got
those fatty cages
it's just a lot of people you know that
are in there probably
oh gosh
best investment or worse investment was
there anything i know it's kind of a
boring question it's not important yes
no i mean i i i can make it cool if i
had something cool right you know that
it's one of those questions like this is
either gonna be really awesome or is
this gonna be like oh this this that was
a dumb question because the gas sucked
yeah did you buy a bunch of sea-doos or
something what happened um you know i
bought a lot of dumb car i mean not like
i just went through a lot of cars yeah
and
you know not super like not two three
hundred thousand four thousand dollar
cars just like your you know your your
mercedes and your
audis and trucks and like i would i
would just go
home a hummer at once at one point
i've had a
toyota land cruiser twice oh yeah those
are sick i've had i mean just like this
dumb stuff and i got to a point i was
like this is stupid like we need to just
stop like just buy a car and just drive
it right
instead of doing yeah the highly short
term one year yeah um what do you think
of that new ford bronco i love it you do
i do wow i like it i i tell you what i
like more and i'm on the on the list for
it is the uh the
the at least
are they out yet weren't they supposed
to be out like what happened i've seen a
couple actually you have like in real
life i sure have out in the wild yep out
in the wild brother i've seen these
things wow roaming the earth dude oh now
that i didn't see that one that's doors
off i didn't know they could do that
what i'm i'm on the wait list for the uh
the hummer ev oh you are yeah the
electric one huh like the top comes off
you bring up that hum ready put up the
hummer overview because i got on the
cyber truck but i can't tell if it seems
cool or not the tesla one yeah
and then i can't tell if you're going to
be able to get your own tires put onto
it or if you have to use the ones that
they give you because of just something
oh wow this is see i feel like this
looks a little chunkier than the bronco
i feel like the bronco looks too small
yeah the bronco is small they like this
i think i think this is gonna be
like you said a little bigger and the
tops come off i mean and it's electric i
feel like i probably should have an
electric car at some point yeah
my life maybe not
i like the smell of gas yeah i mean i've
got to get in on my hands i've got
diesel trucks like i don't oh damn you
got that sweet gas huh yeah so like i
feel like getting getting uh electric
might like even even me out some yeah
doing the right thing backing god's gas
graces
yeah oh that's pretty put up pull up the
one kevin love's always trying to sell
on instagram
what's he selling oh
no kevin love um
[Music]
it's like a woody wagon i think
selling car i don't know nope this woody
wagon what you try
let me see what he's always doing
oh no
it's always on it i just see it did you
make this up maybe oh that thing
[Laughter]
kev club definitely doesn't have a win
that's not it man
he made that up yeah no i there's i
thought it was
some
that's always selling something i tried
to uh i told i have a yoga instructor
this morning i told her i was gonna try
to set you up with her too
uh like for yoga or for a date um for
either one
so her name is emma she teaches yoga and
where she teach that is it good right
here she taught me this morning oh she
comes to your house yeah
oh that's nice
she's um does she do chakras
she might dude she's strong is she i
mean she's a yeah she's a dime i mean
all those all those yoga chicks are
strong like they scare me
yeah i mean don't scare me like that but
they're like
they're strong you ever date a real just
a real no no no
that no that's too much for me it is
yeah that's not that's not my speed you
don't want that hearty panda huh
oh yeah i don't know i definitely did it
ago you got a pat on the back every day
you know in the back kind of pats back
um
yeah i'm trying to think of just one
more anything to think about that dance
i was just thinking about those dances
man that really was fun growing up it
was
i would go and get with your friends and
you all plan to go eat somewhere where'd
y'all go eat at do you remember was like
we went to this place called fazzios it
was kind of dicey and a lot of divorcees
and people would meet up over there
parents to like kind of
low-key try and like sneak around i
gotcha i mean i grew up in a really
small town like and it was just a bunch
of like small towns so it was like you
know denny's was the spot oh yeah the
gadget football games or stuff like you
know go to go to denny's no way oh yeah
it was open 25 i think it was open 24 7.
because it was right off the interstate
but it was like 20 minutes away
um
yeah denny's and it was back whenever
like they had a smoking section remember
the non-smoking and smoking section what
do you remember that you don't it was
probably because everyone louisiana
smokes yeah it was all smoking such as
the whole state of smoking
dude i'm trying to think yeah but that
was always fun man so you go even have
to go eat there before dances even after
after yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was fun dude those are times
that i that i really that i really miss
um it must be interesting being a dad
because you kind of get to have this
nostalgia where you get to kind of see
um the other side of the coin and what
it's like yeah yeah um
i think it's harder to be a kid now
though
i think there's more pressure they grow
up faster um
so i think it's a little bit tougher but
it but it's it's still a joy i mean just
to see them
you know go through some of the things
that you went through and you're able to
help them and kind of you know
you know there's certain things you're
like
i don't want to help you like you've got
to figure this out on your own so it's
kind of this fine dance of like i don't
want to shelter you but i also don't i
love you to death i don't really want to
see you get hurt right and it's like ah
which where where do you where do you
land here on some of this stuff does he
give you a different it gives you a
different respect for your own father
probably oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
cool man absolutely the circle of life
man it's pretty fascinating who were you
cheering for that fight were you
cheering for connor yeah you were yeah
well i mean i i knew but i knew he's
gonna lose
like we had money on russian yeah but
like it would i think it would have been
good for ufc for him to yeah be back in
it but like
we went into the fight saying this he's
gonna get murdered
i wish he would have made it to that
first round who knows what could have
happened i mean he's such a good striker
it would have been i think it would have
been gotten even worse in the second
round you think yeah i think dustin was
going to absolutely destroy him yeah
that's crazy but it's amazing like you
know he's he's talking in the in the in
the talking [ __ ] in the hospital
i'm like what this dude
i wish i believed in myself that much
like it's just
this is in the hospital broken leg just
he's already back
yeah yeah
that's like somebody in a coma and he
finally gets a first word yeah
it's just like [ __ ] like are you
kidding me right now
like it didn't even happen like yeah
like he fell off his bike and broke his
leg that's what's interesting it's
almost like whatever it is it doesn't
even happen he's a king no matter what
no matter what it reminds me of that six
nine have you seen that six nine
documentary oh dude it's really
interesting because he just started
realizing that none of these rappers
were really killing each other anymore
yeah so he could just talk [ __ ] to all
of them because none of them were
actually going to kill him yeah and he
was right he figured it out yeah he
broke he broke the code he's just
calling everybody a [ __ ] just doing
whatever he wants and none of them are
and so then the next thing you know he's
just like look at me he's the man he's a
legend it
that might be how to do life just
maybe it is just not even see all the
social media not even see all the thing
and just be your own thing believe in
yourself to the core a thousand percent
[ __ ] i think we i think we just nailed
it
um best of luck with the new podcast man
you can find it on podcast one
yes and um and we'll put the links to it
below and uh jay cutler's man thanks for
coming in bro i appreciate it was fun
man yeah it's fun man
[Music]
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling like these leaves i
must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
share this piece of mind i found i can
feel
[Music]
a it time
for me to set that parking brake
and let myself on my heart
shine that light on me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Music]
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
[Music]
know